one of the problems people have with
electric cars is charging time yes
modern fast Chargers can get your car to
80% in about half an hour maybe even a
little quicker if you're lucky but
that's a long time compared to the 3 or
4 minutes that it takes to fill up with
petrol or diesel so on a first heard
there was a car company building
automated battery swap stations where
robots will switch out your car battery
in just a few minutes while you stay in
the car I assumed it' be a weird
prototype some pie in the sky technology
from a university that would never
become practical but that is a battery
swap station right there open to the
public so let's see if it works Neo has
more than 2,100 stations operational in
China and the goal is to reach
2,300 by end of year in Europe we
started around 2 years ago and we have
now 30 operational stations in China uh
every day we have more than 40,000 uh
battery swaps being performed one every
two 2 seconds and we have had Peaks
during holiday season more than 60,000 a
day we're not just piloting this it's
already proven at skill as ever this is
not an advert they haven't paid me I
reached out to them they have just let
me borrow a car please press the brake
pedal nicely done now you can tap to
start parking into the Power Swap
station you drive the car in front of
the station and once you park in front
of the the station the car takes over
and it's fully automatic we are parking
now be aware of your surroundings do not
open any door or take over the steering
wheel you can press the brake panel to
control the
speed Neo users if they want to access
the uh powersoft network uh they need to
choose battery as a service so that
means they don't own the battery they
lease the battery and so they can get
the access to the poft station network
you can purchase the the battery and the
car or you can purchase the car but
choose access to the swapping Network
you can also just subscribe to both the
car and the battery the idea is that
you're not renting or buying a specific
battery but you're just paying for that
always being a fresh battery in your car
charging is still a cheaper option but
there are plenty of people who'll pay a
fee for
convenience preparing please wait we can
serve the same amount of uh users
comparable to a charging H but we need
only one 1/3 of the space and we need
1/3 of the grid connection because we
can charge the batteries at their low
speed we provide frequency balancing
Services we charge the batteries at
specific points in time where there is a
need to get rid of all this power and
balance the grid the thing is I've
driven electric cars on long trips
before and charging wasn't really a big
problem it needs a little more planning
than using fossil fuels but turns out I
want to rest at about the same interval
that the car wants charging folks out
there who can drive 8 hours in one go
good luck but I am not one of you the
best way to charge a vehicle is at home
if you have a socket right with Eevee
becoming more affordable there are more
people who want to access an electric
vehicle and don't have the opportunity
to have a socket close to where they
Park their car Shanghai a city with more
than 20 million inhabitants people live
in in big apartments and so on Street
charging it's much less uh than in
Europe people don't have access to home
charging because it's much more dense
City Power Swap offers a great
opportunity uh to just leave your home
drive to the station swap your battery
and continue your trip and of course
there is the catch that this battery
swap station only works for cars that
are built for it you can get a Neo
battery swapped here but there's no
other car on the market that can use
this at least not yet we we have been
signing strategic agreements with big
groups like changan and Jil group we
have gained the confidence of also the
other auto makers there's a opportunity
to standardize this technology uh in
China but perhaps also in Europe we're
going to invest in B Reser service and
we're going to invest in the Power Swap
network if you take the whole economics
we do believe that this is better than
just selling a car plenty of people
electric vehicle enthusiasts stock
Brokers people who bought neostock have
been running analyses on whether the
company's financial model will work
building these stations is incredibly
expensive and it's no secret that Neo is
losing a staggering amount of money
right now but that's the way that
colossal startup companies and finance
work these days they hope the initial
outlay will be worth it in the end that
strategy has paid off for a lot of big
corporations and not paid off for many
more I looked a lot of those financial
analyses while I was researching and my
conclusion is I don't know predicting
anything about electric vehicles is
almost impossible it's an industry
filled with both radical inventions and
broken promises I'm just astonished that
something I thought was science fiction
does appear to be an actual real world
option right now and that a robot just
swapped out my car
battery